Democratic presidential contender Pete
Boudicca joins us now from Concord New
Hampshire first on CBS this morning as
you know he's a former mayor of South
Bend Indiana mayor Pete good to see you
good morning how frustrated are you
today
good morning hello well I think it's
safe to say no one in the country is
more impatient than I am to hear the
official results from the party but
we've also put out the results that
we've got from over 1,200 districts our
precinct organization reported based on
the procedure that they were trained to
do and based on that it was a phenomenal
night for us yeah we heard you say we're
going on to New Hampshire victorious but
how can you do that when the official
results are not in shouldn't you wait
well we we have the results from our
organization and if you look at what we
were able to do what happened last night
the fact that this campaign was able to
gather support in urban suburban and
rural areas alike in counties that
Hillary Clinton won counties the Donald
Trump won we are thrilled and absolutely
considered that a victory the state
party called called the campaign's to an
emergency meeting last night what did
they what did they tell the campaign's
about what the problem was and when do
you actually expect to see official
results you know as far as I know we
still don't have a time for when they're
supposed to let us know the official
results again safe to say nobody's more
impatient than I am given how fantastic
everything we've seen was coming out of
last night but what we do know is that
there is a paper trail that they'll be
verifying this based on paper and given
whatever happened technically that's
good news it's always good to have a
paper trail but to Gail's point mayor
the the Sanders campaign also saying
they're essentially victorious there are
people online saying that your claim of
using the V word is I think the hashtag
is mayor cheat in retrospect you think
it was a little premature to take the
stage and use the V word no I mean
looking at what happened last night
looking at all of the data that we've
got it was an extraordinary night and we
are absolutely victorious coming into
New Hampshire I mean this is a campaign
that when we launched a year ago people
said you're not a senator you're not a
national name what what business does
somebody from a mid-sized city in the
middle of the country have running for
president said we shouldn't even be here
and now here we are in the position that
we are in coming into New Hampshire for
what we think will be another historic
night a week from today no what do you
say now to people who when the results
come in are now questioning the
integrity of the results
well again the good news is there is a
paper process that can verify this and
of course the way the caucus process
works folks are in the room they see how
everybody aligns so it's verifiable but
still very very frustrating you and the
other candidates have been very careful
to not undermine party unity as you
campaign against one another but now we
have this chaotic result coming out of
Iowa does the fact that there are now
multiple candidates calling themselves
victorious does that create chaos that
helps the president it's been a
narrative that the Democrats on the loop
they're doing we're competing and you're
going to see this competition play out
but what we all know and all agree on
are the values that that bring us
together and the absolute need to
deliver a new and better presidency I
would imagine at the White House they
are doing the hula today because it does
look like a hot mess for the Democrats
does it it does what does it say that
the Democrats couldn't get something so
important right right out the gate
well again I'm certainly feeling
impatient and eager to get those
official numbers I hope that doesn't
take away from the extraordinary thing
that happened yesterday that across
communities large and small with a
regardless of how those counties had had
voted in the past including a lot of the
counties that famously swung from
President Obama to president Trump we
have demonstrated the ability to put
together that that coalition that is
going to beat Donald Trump in the fall
all right mayor Pete it sounds like
you're trying to put a good face on a
bad situation where Buddha judge thank
you
you